اعلنت مصادر روسيه ان نظام الصواريخ
الامريكيه المضاد للطائرات تم تدميره في
كييف بواسطه طائرات ميج 31 الحمله
للصواريخ كنجال كان نتيجه كمين جوي محكم
ونقلت وكاله نوفوستي عن مصدر لم تسمى ان
خصائص سرعه صواريخ لا تسمح لها بالوصول
الى اهداف عسكريه في اوكرانيا في غضون
دقائق
وقد رفض منسق الاتصالات الاستراتيجيه في
مجلس الامن القومي الامريكي
تاكيد صحه التقارير عن تعرض نظام باتريوت
الامريكي الصنع للتلف نتيجه قصف روسي على
كييف لكن اصلاح المنظومه من طرف
الاوكرانيين يعتمد على مدى الضرر الذي قد
تكون تعرضت له
لا يمكنني تاكيد صحه التقارير عن نظام
الباتريوت ولكن اصلاحه يعتمد على نطاق
الضرر الذي تعرض له وما اذا كان بامكان
الاوكرانيين اصلاحه ام انهم بحاجه لمساعده
هناك عدد من مدافع التي تعرضت للضرر وتم
اصلاحه بعضها في اوكرانيا بينما ساعدنا
كيف في هذه المهمه خارج البلاد